[MUSIC]
All right, we have some folks joining us.
Welcome.
It gives me no short amount of
pleasure to be able to introduce our
feature panelists today and our speaker.
She, as I mentioned is one
of the icons on campus.
Someone, I have the honor of working with,
the only assistant dean of MBA Admissions
and Financial Aid, Kristen Moss.
So Kristen,
if you'd like to introduce yourself and
maybe any reflections on the week.
>> Well, I must say that's one of
the nicest welcomes I've had in a long,
long time.
So, thank you.
I'm just feeding off
your wonderful optimism,
and I can't believe it's 22,
I think that's right.
Right, Wl, 22 events and
really as I reflect,
it's funny cause we have been planning
this event for quite a long time.
And you're so busy in the weeds
thinking about what's to come,
you don't get a chance to sit back and
ask yourself what we'll feel like.
So it's been wonderful today to just
sit and the emotions of the week and
I think the top one for me is just
a sense of inspiration right now.
And it's inspiration to be
with everyone who's online for
coming on this journey with us.
It's to be working with you Wl and
the rest of the community on this team.
I know we've had students and
alumni and faculty and
staff all come together to really talk
about diversity, equity inclusion.
An important issue and
over the last really
six months with what's been happening
in our world to see one week in time.
Where we can take baby steps to
talk about difficult issues,
has been something that has filled me up.
How about you Wl,
what are your reflections on the week?
>> I feel overwhelm with gratitude,
I would say just being able to
share space with our students.
And just how open they were
with their experiences,
things to think about eat the fears and
hopes.
Inspired by sessions like earlier
we had one with Lord McKenzie and
Sara Suole, talking about not just
the direction of DI at Stanford.
But also ways that we can incorporate
it into our everyday lives.
So just knowing that I'm surrounded
by people who really care is just so
invigorating.
>> Right.
>> And this is already a job that I love.
Like I am an admissions nerd.
But to know I get to work with
people that are also kind of nerds
about the things that they love.
It's just amazing.
>> That's great everyone for
your echoes for me.
And the opening having
Dean John Levin come and
talk about why this work matters to him.
And knowing that he's really leading
the ship at the GSB and to hear so
authentically about not only
how it impacts our institution.
But the rest of the world that gave
me such his values align with so
much that you and
I talk about and work towards.
So to see him speak at that level really
empowered me to continue doing this work.
It's like the North Star
of the school in some ways.
And I know for us this year in admissions,
it's our number one priority is
increasing the DI in our community.
So it was great to see him speak so
much from the heart about it.
>> Yeah, and earlier even Sarah and
Laurie were mentioning how big
changes can happen from small actions.
And it's the things in the here and
now that we do that can have some
pretty amazing ripple effects.
That's awesome.
It kind of feels like we were just
together on the last office hours.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
>> But so much has happened since August.
So I wanted to check in just so we could
share with folks who are tuning in.
Some of you who may have been
part of our last edition of this,
some of the new things that have happened.
And so we need to kick us off with,
can you talk to us about the bold fellows
fund that was just announced in August.
>> Absolutely.
>> want to be able to like,
really highlight some of the things
that are happening here?
>> Yeah.
And I want to make sure I say one more
thing too, because the most recent thing
that just happened with this week.
And this has been an event, so
diversity and leadership for many years.
But it has never been so
comprehensive involving so many people.
And I wanted to speak to why it was
important to me if that's all right for
a moment, and really.
And when we designed this event and
we'll get a lot of the credit.
What's most important to me in serving as
a dean of admission is I believe everyone
out there.
And looking we have 135 people
in the audience right now.
Everyone has potential within them.
And it's our job as admissions officers to
help whether you apply to Stanford or not.
It's really to help you embrace that and
realize that and
part of what we believe in this program.
Is individuals can't really,
we talk about dreams at Stanford, but
we're a place where dreams can come true.
So we all hold them inside our hearts,
but they don't become realized until we
can visualize how to make it possible.
In this week, at least what was
important to me is trying to bring so
many parts of our community together.
So no matter who you are in the audience
and how you see yourself and
your identity.
There are people here at Stanford who we
hope that you could see yourselves in.
And people here at Stanford are all
ready beginning to take those first
steps towards those dreams.
So if you can begin to visualize
what's the legacy I want to leave?
I mean, that legacy I want to leave.
What are the problems I want to solve and
then begin to see yourselves and
some of the role models here.
That was really our hope and our goal.
So hopefully, some of you throughout
this week have gotten one step closer.
To letting those dreams not just
be something you could attain but
to make it real of what
you're going to obtain.
Does that resonate with you Wl?
>> So much.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because I really was the heart of
everything and it's not just
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, this week wasn't about admissions
as much as it was how can we help people.
Like think big and see themselves
in business school in business.
What are some of the ways we can
continue to grow even if you don't go to
business school?
And how can if you do want to go,
like how can we help you put your best
foot forward regardless of where that is.
So, yeah, that was just the heart of
everything that this week is about.
>> Yeah, and I think of all but
literally hundreds of students and
others who have been
involved in having panels.
And being able to take your questions and
faculty, hopefully that was realized.
So let's go back to bold
what you talked about first.
>> Yeah.
>> So
we're launching the balloon fellows fund.
I think John Levin announced
this just a couple months ago.
And what is that about?
And why is it so
important to us right now?
We have been proud at Stanford for
many years about our financial aid model
which is really a need
based financial Aid model.
And that means we want to make sure no
matter what your financial situation is,
that you can come to the Stanford GSB.
And not graduate with
unreasonable amounts of debt.
So we really base our package
on you as an individual.
That being said,
we know that many students have put
away their savings especially
if you're first gen.
Or you're coming from a lower economic
status you may be saving right now,
like our flight club talked about.
You may be saving not only for
this moment in time but also for
the future to help others in
your family or larger community.
So this bold fellows is really for you and
you can apply for it once you're admitted.
And what we do is not only look
at your financial situation.
But also that greater financial
picture with your parents and
greater family included.
So that we can help give a little bit
extra to ensure that you have that
protection over time.
To face whatever financial challenges
might be in the future for both you and
your family.
What would you actually will
has helped create this?
So I'm going to toss it to you and say.
Did I miss anything on that?
>> I think it really speaks to kind of
the spirit of what we do in admissions and
financial aid.
Like in the application process.
We talk a lot about the holistic review.
But like this is our ability to translate
that into the financial aid world.
As well knowing like there are holistic
parts of who you are that might
also need support to and
through the GSB finances is one of them.
And how can we be as thoughtful and
inclusive as possible knowing that
you know we're still learning.
We're still growing.
We're still evolving and we'll always
keep changing based on feedback.
Feedback is a gift.
But yeah, it's I was so
excited for it this year.
>> And I have to say to our alumni,
we've been sharing this idea with our
alumni who are really excited
to contribute to the effort.
And part of where it comes for me too.
Is having really tough conversations
once a student has been admitted.
Even I'm sure this has come up in a week.
Our financial aid packages are generous.
So on average, about 40,000 or
$80,000, over the two years.
Even with that package, just having
insecurity about can I invest in myself
and maybe take some of the resources that
I've saved that my family might need?
And those can be difficult.
So this is the problem that
we've come up to really help.
That pain point.
>> Yeah I know that there have been some
pretty tough conversations recently.
So I'm glad we're like, again,
every step forward is a step forward.
Speaking of kind of steps forward,
we've also taking a step
forward with our class profile.
So we brought in a class with a wish.
[LAUGH]
>> During a pandemic,
it was very exciting.
>> Yeah, so, we'll definitely
talk about that in a little bit.
But I also wanted to have you share
a little bit about our approach to
the class profile and how we're reporting
like who our community is with the public?
>> We wanted them.
In the last couple years we've been
talking about how to make sure for
our applicants who are applying.
They could really understand the richness
of the community at the GSB and
we have published in the past.
What are underrepresented minority figures
are as a percentage of our entire class.
So that would be looking at Asians,
Hispanics, black students,
Native Americans, Hawaiian,
Native Hawaiians, etc.
Together but we've never broken
them apart individually.
This year was and I said this is taken.
We've really had an effort for the past
three years and even prior to that.
But Bunsen burners been going up
a little bit more and more energy and
I was really excited to share that
our profile this year has moved from
I think last year is about 27%
underrepresented minorities to 37%.
Which is a huge movement in the needle and
a year and it really represents a lot of.
Outreach effort that we've
been doing on the team.
Leveraging our students and
others in the community to reach out and
encourage more people to apply, as well
as helping students who are enrolled,
think about the process and
whether they could be at home here.
So first big news for us was we continue
to have a much more diverse class.
But then within that,
what does that 37% mean?
And how can we be more clear about that?
It sounds easy that you could just break
this out by different identity groups,
ethnicities, and races, for instance.
But as will and I continued to look at
the profile of our class, we saw that.
A great number of our students
identify and multi ethnicities and
identities and it's very hard to put
one person in any individual bucket.
So we really came up with multiple
ways to show the class both
from a sense of how is the federal
government regulations?
Look at amnestied but
also how we as the GSB do which is
really from a multi ethnic lens.
[INAUDIBLE] I'm going to pass it to you.
Look at you, you have a slide.
I love that.
>> I stay ready.
>> Visual you're so good.
You want to explain that?
>> Yeah, so I think one of the parts
about this that was so meaningful for
me like I always talk to people about,
like, who are you?
Like what are the different
elements of kind of your identity,
your lived experience that shaped
the way you move through the world?
If you've gone to any of my info sessions,
like you're going to hear that.
And the way that we used to
report by federal guidelines,
we weren't able to capture
some of that complexity.
Especially as it comes to
the identities of folks with mixed or
multiracial backgrounds.
And so with the genius help of some of
the folks in our Central Marketing and
Communications Department.
We were able to come up with a visual
that both acknowledges the separate
kind of components of identity,
as well as the experience and
identity of being mixed or
multiracial in and of itself.
And I know this is a conversation Kirsten,
both you and I have had with students and
also like on the road folks
who are curious to see like.
How does this shape into the experience
because we often hear here is the black
business student association here is
the Asian business student association but
what if I identify with more than one.
And I think this also speaks to kind of
a lot of what's going on on campus when
folks are talking about intersectionality.
When they are working across and
building coalitions, it's kind of
Identity is complex and this is our way
to try and embrace and talk about it.
So I'm really proud about it.
That's why I was like,
>> Magic.
That's fantastic.
Thank you Well, and
it also makes us more accountable.
We said as a school that this
is a priority for us to.
Continue to build the diversity
of our student body.
And here's our first steps
to making sure that happens.
>> And I know that was definitely one
of those big developments for us.
>> Yeah.
>> And, biggest development and
this is where I think we really transition
into some of the things that folks
on this call might be interested in.
Is thinking about like our role in
admissions this year has thrown so
many curveballs our way.
There have been some beautiful,
>> Silver Linings like 37% students of
color.
But can you talk to us a little
bit more about the club
like we brought him a class
that is no small feat.
Can you tell us a little
bit about what happened?
How did we get here?
I know our last office hours
we were in the midst of it so
they couldn't really share much but
now any insights you can provide.
>> Yes, I love how you turn that wheel
that we brought in a class there were
times this year when on
the admissions teams,
we're not sure that we would be able
to do that of any size and my hat.
My hat goes off to many of the folks who
were applying last year and are currently
students and for you, many of you may
be in the admissions process now.
One of the key issues was really
the uncertainty that not only will and
I felt because we weren't sure you
know how we could make decisions
when students couldn't get tests.
Or whether our international
students would get visas or
even whether recommenders could
get the recommendations and
time and everything that we were
struggling with on the other side.
You as an applicant we're also struggling
with so I think the biggest lesson.
That we learned together as a team and
you can correct you can add your two
cents to was Stanford is all about coming
together and caring about the individual.
And trying to make sure that our
decisions have integrity but
also really put you as a student or an
applicant at the heart of those decisions.
So for us,
many of the things we did schools did
different things across the globe really.
But ours we're very focused on
how do we make sure we can.
Help our applicants,
know as much as they can.
Our process can have that integrity, and
that we take your needs
into consideration.
So we ended up, some of
the decisions we made for instance,
is anyone who was an international student
who didn't have a visa come mid July,
that was right before school was starting.
All the embassies were
closed around the globe,
we offered them an opportunity to
have a deferral for the next year.
We also worked with students,
many students.
I shouldn't say many, but
some with COVID had health issues or
family members who had health issues.
So really working one by one with them,
to figure out what was going to be the
best solution, given the circumstances.
And then there was for all the students
who didn't want to come, we had so much
uncertainty throughout the summer of what
would they expect experience looked like.
And I know if you're thinking about
applying this year, you'll be facing some
of those, because COVID is still here,
some of those same uncertainties.
So, our approach really was fireside
chats with the students and
giving as much information as we could.
I to be honest, have been really
humbled by the experience,
because you can't control a pandemic.
And at every moment we tried to be
as really have integrity, and truth,
and be authentic about what we do know,
but
a great hope that the fall would
that we would be able to have.
At least hybrid classes where students
could spend lots of times together.
And that hasn't been the case.
And we don't know what
next year will look like.
So, I'm humbled just by how difficult
it is to want to be optimistic but
also want to be clear, and
let students make the decisions,
given what their position is
at any given moment in time.
>> Yeah, and
how many call do you think, or
fireside chats do you
think you did this summer?
>> We did quite a few.
Yes, for sure.
I think Christine, who runs enrollment
said she had over 171 on one calls with
students out of class of 400,
who really wanted to think through,
whether this was the right time and
the right approach to school.
So that's another example, crazy.
>> Yeah, and it's funny because that
approach like even in our info session
we talk about it all starts with you,
and it is an investment in you,
and we operate in that same way,
like how can we keep you at the center.
So, just really appreciate how you
involved students in the process,
both kind of prospective students and
our current students.
I really appreciated how you got
feedback from students on both bold,
as well as in the process as we were
designing the new class profile, and
the types of information we have.
We're able to share, getting feedback and
actually acting on it, and whether or
not we were able to adopt it, like going
through the honest steps of exploration.
I just want to acknowledge,
and thank you for that,
because I think that's really important,
and just speaks to again,
like the community and
how are we taking accountability for this?
>> Well, thank you Will,
thank you so much.
>> And so, stemming from the COVID
question, I know there's,
it's on a lot of people's minds.
So, I thought it would be helpful to
hear from you, but given deferrals and
some of the decisions folks have been
making for the next steps, like how is
that going to impact or how might it
impact on future classes, will it?
>> Great, great question.
And our class last year for the first,
we had the biggest class ever.
So I'll start there that we admitted, and
it was about 20 students more than
the class before, so about 5% bigger.
And given that we had deferrals,
we allowed our international students
to take deferrals for their visas.
If I had to guess we haven't set our
class size at this point exactly.
But I'm guessing we will keep that size,
I mean it may not be forever but
at least for another year, that will be
but at least those 20 students again.
One of the reasons for
that is when we decided to give deferrals.
We really it was this moment in time
where you want to make sure that
the future applicants so
that was on the calls today,
would still have a good
chance to get into Stanford.
You want to make sure that the current
students would already deposited were
treated fairly, and
then you want to make sure those students
who might not get a visa had good choices.
And so, we really worked with students to
come up with a solution that we thought
would be thoughtful for
all three of those constituent groups.
And what we found from
working with students and
doing some surveys about who was
interested in deferrals, and
whether they would take them if
their visas didn't come through.
It was really a small
percentage of the class.
So, we're feeling that you will have
a good opportunity to find a spot at
Stanford, and we might be a little bit
bigger this year who knows maybe one year.
But we want to again, balance between
all three of those groups to make sure
the process has integrity
across the classes.
>> Also major shout out to the students
who are helping us gather this
information.
>> Like each wave?
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
>> So it's kind of amazing how even the
students were rallying around each other,
to understand kind of each other's needs?
Even before they met
each other in person or
virtually so-
>> Yeah,
many of the international
students were calling me saying,
don't worry I'm working on such and
such I'm just telling no matter what,
he should come even if it's a month
later and it can't get here [LAUGH].
It was great but yeah, we were surprised
even with COVID, how many students from
round one round two who had deposited
decided, that this absolutely you know,
no matter what we're going to come even
with the difficulties we might face.
>> Yeah, COVID wasn't the only thing
that happened [LAUGH] this summer.
>> Yes.
>> DEI, diversity, equity and
inclusion has been like the focus
of this week really, and
given events from the summer,
George Floyd and
Brianna Taylor, rise of and
kind of reemphasis on social justice and
on so many of our like radars.
There have been questions
through the week about,
has this impacted like the way
we think about admissions?
Like, how can we unpack
that a little bit together?
>> Yeah, and together is a good word,
because Bill and
I spend a lot of our free time
talking [LAUGH] about this together.
I've been involved, it's been an honor
to be involved with admissions for
two decades at least.
And I would say even the first role I held
in my early 30s, that was a long time ago.
That was one of my, I would say at that
time one of my top priorities having
whether it's gender ethnicity.
And so it's been a long history for
me personally.
I must say though at this moment in time,
the commitment to really ensure that
insuring at the diversity of your
class matches that of our communities.
That energy has exploded.
So I don't think if I look,
it's always been important to me and
my admissions work, but especially now
it is at the top of the priority list.
And it is a real recognition that this
country is in a place that feels torn
apart, these issues can't stay buried.
So, not only now is it each individual but
it's us coming together.
I feel real change, it's like
a wildfire you start having sparks and
each of those sparks begin to catch on and
that's how this week has felt, but
also how it's feeling at the school.
I mean, whether it's our faculty,
you'll see Huggy if anyone stays on for
his session next,
building new cases around diversity.
Every case that is written this year,
a new case from the dean as part of our
racial equity plan will have
an underrepresented minority protagonis.
The school Stanford is committed to
hiring 10 new faculty member whose
expertise is within this.
And then for us, we continue, now let's
get to the admissions piece of it.
Not only is it building community, so
individuals can see themselves and
believe that this is a place
that might help them.
So an event like we're doing now,
it's also in our admissions process, and.
We have been doing training for many
years on how to think about assessment
within through a diversity lens and
we're continue to do that.
One thing that I think is important and
I think for
folks on this call to understand is.
Assessment is always done within context.
So if you look we look at for
excellence or
impact how people have been
impacting their communities.
And it's really about,
giving the resources that they've had and
giving the challenges they're facing.
So I know for I use this example
oftentimes for one student who maybe
their parents went to college and the
grandparents and their great grandparents,
for another student, maybe they literally
are the first person ever to get there.
Now, just getting to college,
maybe the same kind of accomplishment
as someone who's fourth generation is
to hold an A average, whatever it is.
So that's in context for
us, those are both enormous
challenges that people are facing
from a very different place.
What do you think about that?
>> I, each every sight,
like basically every application I read,
I get this new appreciation of
like the holistic review process.
And like the way it allows us to
understand and who people are,
what their journeys are that excellence
in context because excellence is amazing.
And for us to really
understand what that means for
you as an individual, just like bike
that element of context really,
I think speaks to the integrity of our
process as well and our honest been like.
And how much time we do invest
in trying to understand So
that is definitely
admission nerd speaking,
because to speak about the foundation
of our work is something I appreciate.
>> And I think it's an important point to
make, because there are a lot of myths out
there, that there's only one way to
succeed, or one level of excellence.
However, that's defined and Like we look,
for instance, in our application for
folks who are persistence who have
grit who overcome challenges, and
the myth I'd like to break is for each
of you to ask yourself what is something
that you've worked hard for and
what why was that meaningful to you?
And that could be in college, you had
a job to support you, your family or
your parents or your education, it could
be that you're the first person to get
to college again to use that example.
It could be that you're mentoring
your siblings or your larger family,
these are moments in time where you've
made an effort to support others.
It doesn't have to be necessarily
you were a class president or
the captain of some team.
So what When we look at you holistically,
we want to understand what was important
to you and the actions that you took and
there's no sort of standard for what
excellence means in that in that category.
>> You talked about so some of the things
of excellence, you mentioned like
beater ship and that's actually our area
gritties leadership assessment yeah.
I think that's a great skill set and
vision to have like guide us through
that process and so I actually got
asked this question this summer.
So Michelle, if you're out there,
I am still mulling over this
question that you asked me, yes.
How would you define leadership?
I took a long time to respond
to her then I asked her
to email me a couple days later so
I have more time to think about it.
I'm not going to lie, when she emailed me,
I left it in my inbox for
a couple days, [LAUGH] but
I was still thinking about it and
I continue to change how I approach and
understand that question,
I was wondering if we can
get a sense from you,
given your experience in
the field of leadership?
What are some of your thoughts on
how would you define leadership?
>> For me the definition I have a pretty
simplistic definition which I'll share but
it's not just because something
simplistically defined,
it doesn't mean it's easy
to do have a chat well.
So I think about a leader is someone who
is able to influence others to help them
reach a common goal that's the simplistic
definition, but how does someone do that?
And I know here and I've spent a long time
thinking about this and studying many
other many different leadership
frameworks, and we do an admissions.
We're looking as we're reading these
applications holistically for evidence,
have take leadership behaviors.
So have you been able
to help others achieve
a common goal through your own influence?
There's a different domains of
leadership that help with that and
not everybody kind of spikes, so I'll use
that word, spikes, across all domains.
We often look for candidates who may do
one of these, work with in one of these
domains as a favorite, or
one that really motivates them.
One of the first ones that we
think about in admissions really,
it's how you think,
the insights you have and oftentimes,
I think applicants believe or
it's just my test scores or it's my GPA.
In fact for Stanford that couldn't,
couldn't be farther from that truth.
We really are trying to find evidence
in your application of Have you
had an insight or seeing a problem
that you've solved in a way that has
helped your team shifted
the direction that they might go?
How have you used your thinking so
that others could come together and
get to a place which you've
identified is the right direction?
So that will be an example
of the thinking cap.
You also see leadership,
there is a couple of different domains.
I talked about this persistence,
and grave, and challenge,
that is another place.
We are looking for people who are willing
to take risk and work really hard,
so hey goes to themselves for some
could be the first to go to college for
someone else, it could be winning
a swimming event or a marathon for others.
It could be playing a piano concerto
better than they've ever played it but
we're looking for that evidence
that you're working really hard for
something that you care about.
Now well, there's a couple there's
two other domains I could touch on.
Do you think it would be helpful
because I could geek out on this?
Totally, I'm listening, but
before we go on, I got one comment,
soo are you saying that there
is a diversity in leadership?
[LAUGH] Had to get that in there but yeah,
I would love if you can keep telling us a
little bit more about those other domains.
>> Because that's a great word to use
because within each of these domains, you
could demonstrate it in so many different
ways depending on what your passions are.
The third one the third important
domains is how do you engage others?
So how do you get them excited
about what you're interested in so
you can work together and then the last
one is which I think is important for
this phone call is how do you think about
developing others and it might not just be
individual humans, it might even
be your cultures and I find them.
I know when I was early in my career
a long time ago, it felt like I was one of
the only women on Wall Street and I was
often called upon to run recruiting or
support our marketing campaigns or help
other women who are coming to the firm.
And this can be a big load for anybody
who feels like they might not be in
the majority, they might be in the
minority no matter how that gets defined.
This really translates to investing
in helping the organization as
a culture grow, as well as helping
individuals within that organization.
So you might be someone who mentors others
at work who you might be the person
who teaches the newest
analyst how to do Excel.
No matter what it is,
you might be the one who's helping
your brother learn helping your
brother apply to college there's so
many ways that you could show that
you care about developing others.
So those are just four of the bigger
domains that I think about.
And if you put these together,
you really can influence folks to
join you in achieving great things.
>> And, again, the theme so
many different ways and
even in the small moments In
leveraging sales relationships and
impacting even on that one on one level.
They can have some really outside
outsized results from there.
>> Exactly.
And we want to know about them,
that if that wasn't good,
[LAUGH] we want to hear about them.
So don't ever take yourself
out of the process
because you think that your results aren't
big however the world might define big.
Because that we're not looking for that
we're looking for the impact that you've
had on the people that you care about and
the organizations that you care about.
>> On that point about counting yourself
out I know there is there is a level of
intimidation.
Because Stanford but
the admission rate is this low,
like just going to name it.
Can whatever you What are your thoughts
on it like how might someone approach it
in ARP that admission process or in the
application process in a way that helped
might help alleviate some
of those like concerns.
>> It's a great question,
I want to have a thoughtful answer.
I think first,
we start out at all laugh because
it's an echo of what we said before.
It really starts with you.
So If you're thinking that an MBA so
you're beginning on this journey that you
really need not only the learning but
the community.
As well as a chance to
figure out who you are and
where you want to go if all
that is compelling to you.
And are deciding to embark
on this journey Really My
best advice would be to
look at multiple programs.
Because they do have very
different selectivity rates and
Stanford tends to be one of the ones
that's most difficult and, and
those selectivity actually
vary a lot by by program.
So trying to find programs that
you think might fit you and
embracing that is a journey in of itself.
When it comes to Stanford in particular,
so that makes me feel comfortable saying,
you know what if this is something you're
committing to do, do your homework and
hat and try to have multiple options.
And if you continue to be excited about
Stanford in our little worried weather
That the selectivity rate
would prevent you from coming.
The best advice I can give you is we we've
just shared with you what we're really
looking for.
It's not about a test score,
or it's not about one GPA.
We're looking for reasons to it.
Make you I feel like lucky and I bet well
does as well that we are at Stanford,
we get lots of applicants who have
those great test scores and GPAs.
So we have the flexibility to really look
at who has made contributions to their
communities.
Who could bring us a diverse
perspective into the classroom.
Who is intellectually curious,
and finding new ideas, and
those are at the heart,
the true heart of our process.
So don't take yourself out
just because you can't.
You think you didn't go to the right
college or you're at the right firm or
you're in the biggest industry.
Or your test score isn't
in the the average,
those are not good reasons to opt out.
Now, I guess I conclude to say,
when you sit back and ask yourself,
where have I made a positive contribution
that I'm really proud of, in the last,
since college to now?
If you're not coming up with
a good a couple of good examples,
then maybe Stanford isn't the place for
you.
But that's what we're going to be most
excited about learning is know how.
Because that's our mission, we want you to
go out and not only change your lives, but
the lives of others.
And hopefully at some point,
we'll spread that impact around the globe.
>> Yeah, and there's something to be
said about that reflective process.
And the introspection that
you invest into not just
the application in and of itself, but
>> yeah.
>> As you're thinking about your goals.
So our essay question,
what matters to you, and
that question actually is very
meaningful for so many different levels.
Can you provide insight into like how you
think about like the what matters and
like, how would you approach.
Like, why is that
an important question for us?
>> Right, and I'm going to I'll say one
other thing on the last question and
start right there.
And I bet Aiden,
this resonates with you as well.
That admin weekend and
this happens every year.
I'll have students come up to me and
said, I came this close to not applying.
I didn't think I think there is any way to
get in, I came from a community college or
GMAT score was this or I did my GPA
that first year at school was tear,
whatever it is, and they are like.
I can't believe that I decided
to do it and I'm here.
So just recognize if you are having
those feelings that there is no way.
The only way to find out is to be
courageous and put that application.
Okay, let's get to the what
matters most question.
This was a question that was here
well before I ever took my role and
I'm delighted when I
first started this job.
I remember I was interviewed and
someone said,
Are you going to change
that question like, no,
it's the best question I could imagine for
anyone earlier in their career.
To be answering, there's lots of research
on leadership that shows that by the time
you're in your early 20s,
your values are set.
So the things that you care
deeply about are likely
not to change very much over
the next 4050 years, so
there's no better time for
you to sit back and think, who am I?
How did I become this person?
What are the values underneath
that are important to me and
have been driving my behavior.
Because not not only is it a good time
to check on that because you're those
values are stable, but
also there's been so much research.
That the leaders who are making
large impact in our world do so
through the motivation of
what their values are.
And through their ability to
communicate them to others.
So, as I work as an executive coach
with senior level executives.
It's the first question I ask them, and
sometimes people who are in their 40s and
50s haven't figured this out.
So it is a great time for
you to really understand Who you are and
what's important to you.
So that you have a true north
star to get to at this point
in your at this magical
tipping point in your career.
Now when I look at an essay, I'm really
trying to find the essay the best essays I
shouldn't say the best the essays
that are often compelling that I'm
reading when we when they come across
our desk in the admissions committee.
As I'm reading about a real person and
all of its complexity.
So the more that you try to think about,
what will or I might want to read,
the less it's really going to be you.
There's only one answer.
There's only, there's one story,
your true story of who you are.
It's hard to get to.
It's going to be a little
work getting there.
But that's the story that
we want to know about.
So the best advice I
could give you would be.
Spend some time, trying to jot
down what you think is important,
and will will Jesus too.
And then ask yourself why
why is that important?
And try to continue to go a little bit
deeper and a little bit deeper, so
that when you finally
understand those core values.
You can see how it links back and
the choices that you've made.
But what would you say was
a lot of talking for me?
>> Well, I actually I feel
very much the same way and
I actually continue to ask myself what
matters and why a periodic basis.
It's actually a really
interesting exercise to do and
it's nice because I don't have
the pressure of trying to apply somewhere.
I'm able to experiment with
the way I approach it.
So yeah, for folks who are.
Aren't in the thick of applying.
I think it could be
something interesting to do.
And then maybe ask a friend or
someone to do it with you, and
then kind of talk about
it was a great idea.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> That's one way also to put words
to something that just feels you.
because sometimes those parts of you are
hard to articulate because they're you.
And so, yeah, and trying to do that
I found that to be really helpful and
big decisions in my life
independent of school.
>> We hear too on our panels from students
that they believe one of the most powerful
things they've done in their own
development was that exercise.
They don't necessarily feel at the moment
they had to write that essay that it was
going to be so powerful, but
hopefully it will give you good incentive
that later when they reflect they realize
how helpful that was to understand
where they want to go next, right.
>> Kind of similar in
the vein of core values.
We do have a question from Angelica about,
Kristen mentioned that values
are set in your early 20s.
Pretty set for the next 30, 40, 50 years.
How does an individual
express their value?
Does how an individual express
their values evolved over time?
What are your thoughts on that?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Really thought provoking question.
>> [LAUGH] It is, and
was funny to hear you say,
well the same thing that you reassess and
look back.
I think the core things that you
value will stay the same, but
the way that you will find to express
them, whether it's in your work,
your family, the things you do outside of
work, will shift as you grow and mature.
But they will be your probably your true
north guiders that sit underneath it.
>> Yeah, and there's a range
of questions in the Q&A box.
So for folks who are tuning in,
we are shifting into that direction.
A lot of the things that we were talking
about have been either industry or
academic background agnostic.
And so what are your thoughts on like, for
folks who are thinking about applying but
don't know, you mentioned earlier I'm
not from the top firm or maybe I'm
not from an industry, quote unquote,
I'm from a non-traditional industry.
>> I love that.
>> How do you think that contributes to,
those perspectives
contribute to the class?
>> Wow, that's fantastic question.
Diversity, we've been talking about many
different kinds of diversity, but that and
industry in your professional work
experience is one of the key components of
how we build diversity in the class.
So while some of you from traditional
industries are worried that you might not
stick out because you're
from consulting or finance.
Others from an industry like education or
energy may feel also that you're not
going to get in because you're from
something that's very different.
Literally, when we are looking at
those files, we're trying to create
a conversation in each and every classroom
where you can have these dialogues.
So you might have someone,
it's not only the industry.
Well in the energy in the solar
business I was doing it this way.
Well when I worked at the NBA
this is what it looked like,
that's how you have some dialogue.
But it's also to industry we
look at what your function is.
So it's wonderful to have someone in the
room who's actually had to sell something,
who's had to build something,
to have the engineer.
We have doctors and lawyers, we have a
pastor, we have a professional violinist.
[LAUGH] So there are many different
ways that they can bring their point of
view to solving different problems
that are in the classroom.
>> Yeah, and it comes back to anchoring in
yourself and the perspective you bring.
Dean Levon actually opened leadership,
well I kind of stole his
thunder because I quoted him.
>> [LAUGH]
>> because I didn't realize what he
was going to talk about.
He spoke about education fundamentally
being about engaging and encountering
difference, and how that kind of has you
challenge kind of your own worldview.
And even if you don't have to accept or
agree with everything, these are different
ways for you to continue pushing
the boundaries of your understanding.
So it's kind of nice how this
does come full circle, and
how diversity really is a critical
part of both our identity as
an institution and how we want to
keep evolving over time, so.
>> I want one other thing since we're
talking about applications, thought Will,
is another misconception I believe
is that you are your industry,
if that makes sense.
That somehow we're reading all the energy
or all the education or the healthcare,
and that so much of your application is
because you have learned about this thing.
What I found fascinating over a couple
decades is I can read 15 different
people who are doing say private equity or
consulting, whatever it is.
And the way that they show leadership or
the way that they've impacted
others varies dramatically.
So this industry, it's not as if
it's the lens we're looking at you.
It's just one of those things
that are in your context, but
please don't feel that
that's what you represent.
We're much more interested in what you
have done within your organization, and
that even the same company can
be dramatically different.
>> Yeah.
There's a question here from Hiskey.
And this is a question that really speaks
kind of to a lot of the work I do.
So that's why I'm kind of
bias towards this question.
What are some future initiatives that
the mission team has in the pipeline and
is excited about?
>> Well Will,
why don't you start with that one then?
[LAUGH] I'd love to toss it to you.
>> I'm really excited about not
just expansion of audiences and
trying to really help folks
see themselves at the GSB.
But how can we also leverage the work
we do, the reach that we do have,
to help people put their best foot forward
regardless of what they end up doing.
So they might apply somewhere else,
they might decide to stay in industry.
But in our outreach efforts can we
do some of the things that kind
of challenge you to have that
audacity to believe in yourself.
>> Aah, love it.
>> Or understand yourself,
these new ways so that you can-
>> I love it.
>> Have that creative confidence
to see something through or
try something different.
And so while it's not necessarily a
tangible, singular thing that we're doing,
I think it's almost that philosophy
that under the kind of the spirit.
And actually that was a lot of what
I hoped to develop with diversity and
leadership this week, to kind of it
not just be about admissions but
are there things that
people can take away?
Whether it is realizations about
themselves or maybe small actions they can
do in their everyday lives around the
topic of diversity, equity, and inclusion.
So super thank you for
posing that question.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, it's awesome.
>> This is something that is so
meaningful for me, and
this is almost like my what matters.
>> That is great.
I love it, Will.
And I think it really captures,
I'm lighting up because it captures,
if you think about our presentation,
even from the last decade,
it's not here your classes,
here's what the clubs are.
It's really who are you and
what do you want to do?
And I think I share, Will,
with you so I aligned so
closely that our hope is that we're
helping you get in touch with what
you want to accomplish no
matter where you apply.
And certainly Stanford may not be
a good fit for every individual, so
it's great to be an admissions role where
your true purpose is helping people
reach their potential no matter where it's
going to be the right place for them.
So so well put, Will, thank you.
>> You could tell I get really
>> [LAUGH]
>> Again, admission nerd.
>> Stanford, yeah.
That's awesome.
>> So this is going to put
you in a hot seat, Kirsten.
>> Okay.
>> And this is a question from And again
to everybody out there, your answer is
your own and celebrate that, but we're
curious with Kristen in the here and now.
>> Yes.
>> And what matters to you, why?
>> It's so funny that I didn't even see
this question on the list, but I love it.
It's very close well to what you said,
my whole career if I could look back and
connect the dots has been
about trying to help people.
Essentially, know what's
important to them and
have the courage to step in and
expand what they think they're capable of.
And I've been really lucky to not
only be doing admissions work,
but also had a chance at Stanford for
many years to work in the classroom.
And of course,
we call interpersonal dynamics to help
people with their leadership skills.
After I left Stanford before
I came back again as Dean,
I was working in the private sector
in an executive search firm,
doing lots of coaching
with senior executives.
So it's so much a part of who I am.
And in this role, it's a wonderful
platform to be speaking with
applicants who are early in their careers,
almost every day
about what they want to accomplish and
how we could help them get there.
And that really is what's
most important to me.
>> Thank you.
I know that can often be a really
question.
>> I know it kind of sucks.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> I know it's hard to answer that
question on this-
>> No.
>> But actually, thank you for
embracing that question.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think that's just something
fun to hear from the leader
of our admissions team to hear what
some of your guiding principles are.
>> I'll say one more thing about it too.
I feel on this role different
than other times in my career.
It's an enormous responsibility.
Because if at the heart, you're trying
to help people develop and we have
an opportunity to come to a place that
Will and I both deeply believe in making
those decisions thoughtfully and trying
to do them with fairness and integrity.
And trying to bring in so many, as we
said, diverse perspectives and class.
It's a lot of responsibility to do
that right for the institution and
do it right for
everybody who's on this call,
to treat each of you with the dignity and
respect you deserve in the process.
>> Yeah, so we are starting to
creep up to the top of the hour.
If you could have any parting
words of wisdom advice,
something that you hope
folks can take home
with them after today's session Kristen,
what would that be?
>> The top card is believe in yourself,
invest in yourself,
but may not be the NBA
that's the next step.
But challenge your dreaming and
your visualization from all of
the wonderful stories you've heard about.
How will you step into your own power?
How will you be brave because we need you?
The world needs you.
So that's my top card.
And then the second card, and I'm feeling
this much more in the last month as
COVID continues,
the pandemic continues to heat up,
is be thoughtful about,
know that this is a difficult time.
And for you as an individual right now,
think about your current situation, what
you're learning, how much you can learn,
how whether it's social justice or it is
the pandemic is affecting that runway that
you have over the next year to 18 months.
because it is a difficult time for
everyone.
And whether if you want to
come to business school,
it's not like it was two years ago.
Probably your job is not
exactly like that as well, so
just take some time to think for
such a big investment.
And what in the world isn't
the uncertainty, what's right for you?
What does that trade off look like?
And hopefully, you can get some
good advice from mentors around and
folks like us on our team to help you get
a greater clarity about that decision.
But at the end of the day,
there's no perfect choice.
>> Thank you for those words, Kristen.
>> Yeah.
>> And so with that, to everybody
who has joined us, thank you so
much over the course of this week.
I hope you've been able to not just get
a sense for who we are at Stanford,
but I hope you're able to also get
some insights into the process and
hopefully insights into yourself.
As you're able to unpack and untangle
all of the different things that make
you who you are, I really hope that
also provides some of those lenses for
you to really appreciate and
understand those around you with empathy,
thoughtfulness, and curiosity.
Because that's the way that we're really
going to be able to get out there and
solve the world's problems working
together across difference,
celebrating that difference and
realizing the potential that
diverse perspectives have to offer.
So with that, this is going to be
the last time this bubblehead will be-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Signing off.
I wannna thank you again,
we have one more event for Diversity and
Leadership 2020 Connect With Community.
This evening, Professor Huggy Rao
will be doing one more case study and
featuring a very special guest.
So while I'll be behind the scenes,
this is going to be my goodbye to you.
Hopefully, we'll cross paths again soon.
And until then, take care, stay safe and
keep asking yourself what
matters to you and why.
[MUSIC]